hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage I'm your host Mike McCarty
here with GameSpot's Miguel concepción
and we're joined by ash from Square
Enix's Final Fantasy 14 team you're here
to talk about storm blood I am
yes panshin second expansion after
heavens board it is yeah so uh so tell
us like for people who are just coming
in fresh what are we expecting with this
expansion well first of all with fantasy
xiv online i don't know if you're
everybody that watches kind of
understands it's an MMO subscription
based MMO it is a celebration of
everything Final Fantasy the music the
themes the characters everything it's
incredible it's got this main story
quests that kind of rivals all the other
mainline Final Fantasy's as well
sure so storm blood so our second
expansion it's continuing that story
we're going to liberate all amigo and
check out the Far East and going to DOMA
but it's coming out June 20th and we're
really excited cool yeah as you just
mentioned like you said a few story
beats that I don't recognize I'm not
just into the I have not played much of
the game but storm blood I'm actually I
was telling you right before we started
I'm really interested in storm ugh
because I've heard it's actually gonna
can bring people in right there's a few
different options for people just
getting in but how do you think I'll be
overwhelmed by the story stuff when I'm
jumping in so I I would say I wouldn't
skip the story stuff so basically I'm
just can I go back to what we're talking
about with storm but releasing we're
also releasing the option for you to
purchase the ability to skip the story
of Rama born and also a realm reborn
plus heavensward
and also level up one of your jobs to
level 60 I wouldn't suggest it now
because the the main story quests here
is kind of what sets Fantasy 14 online
apart okay from some of the other MMOs
out there but even if you did you have
the ability to catch up on all of the
story in in an end in the game it's go
to that's called the unending journey
you click on it has every single main
story cinematic that you can actually
watch sure yeah but it's it's just such
a good story I don't know why you want
to yeah yeah in keeping with the Far
East setting of this expansion this is
an opportunity to introduce the samurai
class along with the Red Mage yeah
that's more about them yeah so the red
mage and samurai are kind of
fan-favorite jobs from the final fantasy
fan
the whole fandom and first time they're
gonna be in the game you know made a
class for samurai obviously and York I
think you've seen some gameplay of it
right now
yeah the Red Mage is kind of a hybrid
both of melee and ranged DPS I'm
particularly probably gonna be trying
out the Red Mage where I actually have a
level 60 black mage so oh yeah I'm more
of a range guy myself but yeah I mean
people have been clamoring for these for
these new jobs so it we're really
excited about that - cool yeah and then
there's like you have typically no new
dungeons new raid of course yeah so you
have all the content that kind of
typically comes with this but one of the
cool things is one of the new raids is
actually based it's called return to
Ivelisse it's kind of based on if you're
a fan of Final Fantasy one of the one of
our past Final Fantasy titles actually
the one of the designers that worked on
that is actually working on the scenario
for this as well cool it'd be the
original director of final fantasy 12
yes oh it's just a cool all right sorry
I was gonna say the dungeons you know
obviously with every expansion we have a
lot more dungeons that are had it at
that time but also as the game is
released we have a patch cadence that's
pretty pretty consistent like every two
to three months usually get additional
different content but there's a lot of
cool new zones obviously you're going
through but the big thing is I would say
we've been clamoring and hinting at
going to all amigo and liberating all
amigo for the last two years so that's
gonna be a really big thing for us here
and it's a I think people are waiting to
finally see where that goes in the story
and if if you have caught up on the
story you've noticed there's been a
couple characters come go set - and you
Geary that have come in from the far
east and all that's gonna play them
together so yeah I'm curious for people
you know veterans of the game and we've
been playing you know since you know a
realm reborn launched and you know
heavens ward but I'm curious how in
terms of quality of life and just minor
changes or even overarching changes how
does storm blood like change the game
itself yeah so there's a sheet of Suns
development we've actually implemented a
new kind of like a battle system revamp
where they've streamlined a lot of the
job actions spells that were consistent
in the previous game and the expansion
beyond that there's also kind of job
role actions that are shared amongst
tank DPS share heals and streamlines
that as well and we have I don't know if
you see on the screen here on the top
right there's a job gauge now that kind
of gives you a better visual indication
of what your specific job actions are
for that job so for the samurai you see
that red sword up there with 100 and the
three icons there kind of gives you a
better visual indication when you can
use sort of certain job actions okay and
the one thing I'll say too is if you
this game is available on PlayStation 4
and PC and Mac with the with the
controller the streamlining of the job
actions is actually going to make that a
much better experience as well - okay um
but yeah I mean I think that the the
battle system revamp is really going to
give the veterans of the game something
to come back and really get sink their
teeth into and really like the quality
of life improvements that come with it
so I hear the fans are also very excited
about the overhaul with the inventory
system yeah if you can talk more about
that big I mean other than basically
we're giving everybody a bit more
inventory so access to inventory haven't
yet I mean that was necessarily
something everybody was always climbing
for as well but I mean with this game -
obviously I talked about the main story
quest but this is an MMO right so we
have housing customization options you
know cut getting your own airship
everything of that nature that comes
with an MMO hundreds and hundreds of
side quests as well beyond just the main
story quest and all the new crafting
recipes and spells that you know that
will come with the game as well so I
imagine must be tough for the
development team to balance you know
like MMOs can be intimidating people not
like into them but I mean of course
Final Fantasy you can attract fans of
that series who might not normally play
MMOs right but I imagine it on the
development side it must be difficult to
balance the accessibility without
sacrificing the depth yeah I mean I
don't want to speak on behalf of the
normal team for that point but what I
would say personally from as an anecdote
to me is I've been playing ever since
back annex altima online or all the time
what I found interesting about fantasy
xiv is that it really melds all of the
great quality of life improvements and
systems that you've seen throughout the
years progressing with mmo's with a
Japanese RPG and a mainline Story Final
Fantasy all-in-one and to me that kind
of makes it a really unique because you
don't really see that in the marketplace
magis now that's coming here yeah yeah
Miguel you've gotten the chance to see a
little bit of the game you know in past
like demos and whatnot right like from
your perspective what is it that sets
you know storm but apart from other
expansions or just 14 apart from other
MMO is in general well the one thing
that
really very much enjoyed in final
fantasy 14 in general is is the balance
of content for playing with friends plus
there's a really really substantial
component where I could just like play
by myself I did that for the most part a
starting actually to play myself yeah
for the most part but then I started
getting in my free company and started
getting other people to play with me but
if you are someone that really just
enjoys a single-player final fantasy
mainline game like I said not only is
the main story quests but it feels just
like that epic journey kind of as you as
a warrior of light so that that's always
cool and that's there but as you want to
participate in things like dungeons and
raids and also for people that are kind
of new to coming into the game veterans
have the ability to queue with their
daily they're essentially they have a
daily roulette which they can basically
randomly go into a dungeon and that bill
level essentially down to that players
level so that you're constantly getting
veteran players also interacting with
new players ok so you and that's and
that's all there for you as an option
for you to queue a lot of quality of
life with that as well I should for
dungeon final raid finder but if you
didn't want to you could just mainline
through the main story beds if you
wanted but you guys aren't shy about
having a lot of exposition and cutscenes
it's about a fancy game right come on
right but it's got all the incredible
things such as your defensive music art
style everything you can thing and
there's obviously there's a lot of
references to the franchise that's a
celebration so you got sit in there
you've got a lot of other familiar
things primals that are very familiar to
my fantasy as well side note what is uh
what are these chests doing so this is
actually a boss encounter in one of the
new dungeons and this is part of the
dynamic of defeating this block ok
interesting one yeah there's a lot of
cool mechanics that you see shariah boss
battles as well we're actually
showcasing one of the primals here at 93
ok and you if you give me that you get a
chance to win a shirt it's cool cool but
yeah awesome and I yeah so I mean a
storm blood you said it's early access
very soon 2 a.m. tomorrow yeah shake it
so if you pre-ordered and actually
that's you could still preorder all the
way through the weekend and just join
while all the excess is coming on ok
going on cool and then I make out do you
have any other you were talking a little
bit about the accessibility for
newcomers and
different options that they have if you
can talk more about that well there's a
howl of novice in the game that kind of
helps bridge your ability to learn about
your job there's this company called the
guild has which actually is a training
group of quests essentially of how to
work in a group but everything else like
all of the new player experience in
terms of the questing everything it
eases you into the game played pretty
well I mean they've done a great job of
doing that
yeah yeah could you detail actually I
you might touch on it earlier the
monetization to actually up your oh it's
nice this is where we have a store
called mock station where you can
actually buy customized customizable
options for your character in that and
mounts and other things and we're
actually launching three new items one
of them being the ability to skip the
story for a realm reborn sure another
one is to skip all the way up through
heaven towards your break or storm blood
and one that also allows you to take a
job up to level 60 and just be ready for
storm about the get-go I really you know
while that option is there um I really
do suggest people playing through the
main story Chris because unlike some
other LMOs like our main story quest
beyond just the game itself through all
the patches
it's continues all the way through and
with each patch you're getting
additional story content and you're
gonna miss quite a bit of context to be
to share straight in the storm but
without understanding what's going on I
guess that way the options there though
right is we do want to make that option
available for new players if they want
to be jump with everybody who's been
waiting for a long time and sure maybe
just and like I said they can go into
game and in any--in you can catch up
with a story and go through cinematics
oh sure yeah um I don't know Miguel you
have any other questions about the
occasion yeah not to jump back like a
dozen topics but as someone who really
loved Final Fantasy 12
um if you talk more about the return to
evil East content I mean it's more than
just a rake yeah it actually can't go
into anything really more about that I
don't really know much myself we are
keeping it kind of close to the heart on
there but they are at what I've heard
and what I've been told from everybody
is that if you are a fan of Ivelisse and
and that were
you are going to enjoy this rain content
is that available not at release it'll
be patched announcing all right yeah how
often I don't mean like a square enix
some units I spend like keeping up to
date between expansions on patching and
updated what's open right we have an
incredible cadence like and like I said
we're constantly adding new content so
every two to three months and next dates
back to the last three years you're
getting two new dungeons one two new
dungeons you're getting quality of life
improvements and some of them depending
on what the patches are but you're
definitely getting a stream of content
all throughout the year and like I said
that main story quest also continues
throughout that entire patch content and
I think if I remember this correctly the
patch content between a realm reborn and
heavens ward was almost as much main
story content as heavens ward itself and
the same thing has happened since
patches came there very meaty content
sure cool oh well anyway yeah I June
20th yes we can play storm bud or early
access to a.m. tonight tomorrow yeah
well not gonna get very much sleep nope
yeah
perfect timing the end e3 but ash thank
you so much thanks so much
stop it on stage Miguel thank you as
well we are gonna throw it back to the
downstairs stage we have Xavier woods
and Samoa Joe are gonna be playing games
on our downstairs stage Xavier woods is
a Final Fantasy 14 fan yeah plays a ton
of games so he'll be down there if
you're WWE fan you can check that out in
about 15-20 minutes we'll go down to
there but of course in the meantime you
can keep up to date with all of our
stage demos all of our developer
interviews throughout III and we will
see you around